it's really important to strike when the
iron is hot because those moments of
willingness like I'm ready to change
they they're fleeting and they pass
quickly so when you notice yourself
experiencing that level of willingness I
think it's important to develop what the
reflex or the habit of actually
Translating that as immediately as
possible into doing something like
taking an action a specific action
that's repeatable being aware when that
willingness arises and then the
bricklayer piece of like I I'm willing
right now what can I do what choice can
I make in this moment that's going to
kind of just tweak my trajectory a
little bit and then how do I build upon
that protect and prioritize the
repeatability of whatever it is I just
did how to then create momentum and then
respect that momentum you string
together even a couple days of something
that's real and that's something that I
think you have to really uh respect
again